shh
all right everybody hopefully you
enjoyed my beatboxed intro of course i
did not
get the real intro set up today as my
producer abandoned me
for some kind of actual event that is
not my weekly chess class
but i hope you are all here joining me
anyways
for this edition of the end game class
uh of course
this is the class where we look at end
games i know you wouldn't expect it from
the title but that is what we do here
last week i did a one hour lecture on
corresponding squares
and i bet you thought we were done
didn't you i bet you thought you could
escape
there's no escaping though no escaping
the corresponding squares
i highly recommend you guys check out
that lecture
first uh before watching this lecture i
am going to do a five to ten minute
recap over everything we've gone over so
far
but it is some very complex ideas and if
you have absolutely no primer
on what corresponding squares are or
what we're doing
with them then you might end up getting
a little bit lost
but with all that in mind what we talked
about last week
was how you can go about choosing your
corresponding squares
the first time i ever taught a lecture
on corresponding squares i did not even
know this method
existed i read about this method pretty
recently in a book
called comprehensive chess endings by
averbach
i think the actual chapter on
corresponding squares was written by
zarin a uh very famous king upon endgame
composer
and uh they suggested this method
where you look at the key squares and
you look at the shortest path
between the key squares and with that
shortest path
you sort of have all the information you
need to create a system of corresponding
squares there are only so many
systems of corresponding squares to
choose from and you can choose between
them
based on the shortest path and the shape
thereof
so one of the studies that we talked
about in the previous lecture was the
one that you see on your screen here
so just as a recap i wanted to go over
this one again
i'm not going to ask you guys to solve
it i'm just going to sort of review what
it is
and how we get there and then we'll move
on into some new territory today
uh of course in the first lecture we
talked about
the eight square triangle system you use
uh sort of a triangle of squares and
then you build out
the squares around it to get uh eight
full corresponding squares
then from those eight squares you can
expand them as
far as you need to uh to solve the study
so first and foremost our first job is
to find the key squares in the position
so key square number one of course is
going to be the square d6
of course the key square is a square
that if your king lands on it
then you win the game right so if the
white king gets to d6
doesn't matter where the black king is
we're always going to be able to invade
over here take a pawn
take the e6 pawn easily winning right
key square number two you might expect
to be the square of f4
but it turns out uh from f4 if the black
king is on h5
we're not actually going to be winning
we would have to retreat our king right
so f4 is not quite good enough however
g4
and g5 very much are so we have this one
key square over here
on d6 and we also have these key squares
over here of g5 and g4
now our next step of course is
constructing the shortest path between
the two
so what do we have here well we have c5
d4 e3 and f4 for white right
this is our shortest path between the
two now for black
you can uh go e7 to defend the key
square
f7 g6 and then finally h5 to defend
the other key square of g4 i'm not going
to really include g5 it
of course is a key square but for all
intents and purposes g4
is the closer square that white is is
threatening to come to
so these are our shortest paths
for both sides right we have this path
for black
e7 f7 g6 h5 and this path for white c5
d4 e3 f4 and the idea that was
introduced last lecture
is how to use this shortest path
to determine your system of
corresponding squares
and of course in that lecture i
recommended the first thing you look for
is the possibility to construct the
eight square system
which is possible here how do you know
if you have an eight square system
well if you have two squares uh
diagonally adjacent
like this one linking square in between
and these five squares around the
outside around the outside
around the outside all available to you
and
same goes for black here the linking
square
and the squares around the outside as
they say
right so you construct this system of
corresponding squares
we're going to get rid of these other
two squares on the shortest path for now
just for clarity's sake
and what do i mean by this is our system
of corresponding squares
well these squares all correspond one to
one
none of them uh
no one square in this eight square
system respon
uh corresponds to two squares in the
matching eight squares they're all
one to one so this square corresponds
to f7 this one to g6
this one to h6 f8
g7 so on so forth
etc right so you have this corresponding
squares system set up once again
eight squares for white eight squares
for black
all from the shape of the shortest path
and then
because it is a system it can be
extended how does it extend
well the squares sort of leap frog over
each other this one
also corresponds to b4
so if a king is on b4 black has to step
to the corresponding square
that corresponds to d4 so of course
for black that would be f7 so b4 d4 and
f7 are all linked
same goes for b3 it leap frogs from d3
to b3
d2 leap frogs from d2 to b2
it also goes in this direction so d3 and
d1
c3 and c1 and in fact b1
and d3 and d1 are all the same we can
even
use the a file as well to go from c2 to
a2
right now i'm going to get rid of these
confusing arrows once again this was
covered in the last lecture so it's just
a review here
so what square should white step to
in order to win this game well let's
think about it right
black is on the h8 square which
corresponds to the c2 square
so to win the game we want to step to
the square that black is already on
because black then cannot access that
square so of course the winning idea
here
is king a2 stepping to the corresponding
square
of h8 which we built using our system of
corresponding squares
so king a2 would win the game after
something like king g8
he is on the square that corresponds
with c3 now
so we go to a3
king f8 now and black is
losing control over the corresponding
square with d2
d2 corresponds with h7 black cannot make
it that far
so white is happy to go to b2 now then
for example
came back to g8 uh would be met
with let's see what is that going to be
met with let's build our little squares
here
uh that would be met with king c3 right
the corresponding square
king c3 king g7 king d3
and now you see black finally has to
decide between these two squares
if he goes to f7 we go to the
corresponding square
and now black must decide which square
on the shortest path
to go to if he goes this way we go the
other way
and get to d6 he goes this way we go
this way
and get to g4 thereby winning the game
so this was the first system of
corresponding squares that we looked at
here the
uh eight square system involving this
triangle pattern that we see from the
shortest path
two squares one linking square and the
five squares on the outside
for both sides now obviously this system
requires a lot to be available a lot of
squares to be available for both sides
to work out
so what do you do when there aren't that
many squares available to both sides
well that's when you go
to the second thing that we looked at
which is of course
the quadratic system and the quadratic
system is actually far
simpler than the eight square system so
why include the eight square system at
all
well because you must use it whenever
you can the quadratic system
does not work when the eight square
system is available
so you can only go to this other system
if the eight square system you've
already tried
to make work and failed because it just
wasn't available
so then going to the quadratic system
there are two ways
to sort of think about it way number one
here
is very similar to the last system that
we looked at the shortest path is still
the same
the only difference here is we've
included these two pawns
which of course uh denies white access
to this e2 square and because white is
denied that access
he cannot construct this eight square
system because e2
is unavailable so what happens then well
we fall back to our quadratic system
quadratic of course if you're familiar
with any math terms
means a shape with four sides in this
case it's going to be
a square so we can make our square
using this same base little triangle
here
uh but instead of making all eight
squares we pick the side
where we can make a two by two square
which is in case going to be
in this case going to be like this right
so we do the same thing for black we
have g7
and then this side corresponds with this
side so f8 and g8 again
we did all this last time um
and now c4 is going to correspond to
f8 c3 to g8 d3
to g7 and d4 to
f7 if i get all my squares right so once
again
this is our system and just like in the
previous case
this system can be extended with the
same leapfrogging type of gesture so d4
is going to be the same as b4 d3 as b3
d2 is going to be the same as d4 and
so on and so forth so what move is going
to be winning here
for white well let's
think about it black is on h7 which is
sort of the same
as f7 what corresponds to f7
well let's take a look here it's
going to be the square don't want to
mess this up
don't want to be embarrassed forever of
course f7 corresponds
to d4 right that's our square on the
shortest path
so d4 extends out to b2 so king b2
wins the game now no matter where black
steps
he steps to g7 for example
we have these four squares in these four
squares g7
corresponds to d3 so king b3 makes sense
uh now we have something like king f7
for example f7 corresponds to d4 so king
b4 should be played
king g8 now for example
would correspond to d4 goes here
d3 goes there g8 is
the same as c3 so king c3 would now
win the game for white
uh and just for example king f8 means
king c4
if you go here we go
here i believe to the corresponding
square and
black has to give up on the shortest
path
right same as last time white is going
to end up winning
because of the corresponding squares f7
is a better try but we still stepped
the corresponding square and now just as
in the previous case
black must choose a side on the shortest
path and white can go
in the other direction alright that was
our supposed to be 5 to 10 minute review
maybe it took more like 15 minutes but
that's okay
so questions on this system that we went
over last week
before we move on to some new studies
questions here this is all on
leeches.org by the way i should mention
i don't even know if i put that
in the title i did yeah it is
onlychest.org
so any questions here i know i went
through this
pretty quickly is it like stepping into
opposition
so yeah the way that i would
characterize it compared to opposition
is the opposition is like a form of
corresponding squares not so much the
other way around
corresponding squares is sort of the
general idea the the base of theory
the systems that uh they're it's like
the mechanics behind opposition it's
it's how it works
when is it safe to approach closer so
whenever you can
approach closer you should when can you
approach
closer well you can approach closer when
black is unable to step
to a corresponding square
for you so for example here after king
b3 king g8
it would not be safe to approach closer
i believe
because well actually in this case it
would but after king b2 king g7
it would not be safe to approach closer
to b to c3
because black could step to the
corresponding g8
compare this with king b3 king g8 now
black cannot step to g8 because he's
already on g8 so king c3
would be a winning move okay
all right well then let's move on to
some new studies hopefully you guys
have a good idea of what we're looking
at here i want to start off a little bit
simple
so we have in this case uh sort of a
simple version
of one of the various systems that we
looked at before
so what's step number one step number
one is identifying the key squares and
you guys might recognize this system
uh this study from the first
corresponding squares lecture i ever did
but here we're going to try and look at
it from this new perspective
of our shortest path system
so what are the key squares i mean yeah
key squares that's what i'm asking about
i remember
so f4 is definitely a key square and
then c7 is a little deceptive uh c7
in fact is not going to be a key square
for us
uh for one king e7 would still be boxing
our king out
uh but then you could argue that d8
would be a key square in this case
due to blacks uh having counter play
black has counter play here
d8 is not going to be a key square
because if you start going all the way
up to d8
black's going to come this way and take
all your pawns and then you're going to
lose the game it's just too far away
so f4 is one key square and there's
actually sort of a hidden
second square that chess king has
pointed out here it's the e5 square
now how can e5 be a key square when it's
defended by a pawn
well if you imagine that the black king
is sort of not uh defending the e5
square
then if the white king is attacking the
e5 square
we have this option to play the move e5
and it turns out that this position
is in fact just going to be winning
white can now go and collect on this
pawn
no or this pawn sorry not like that or
this pawn no matter where the black king
is
so that makes e5 a key square thanks to
this extra option
for white to push his pawn to e5
so we have our two key squares now what
is the shortest path between these two
squares
for each side
what is the shortest path between these
two squares
for each side we have our key squares
so what is the shortest path
for each side
so yeah d4 e3 for right white is
absolutely correct
it's the shortest path between the two
and f6 g5
is also absolutely correct so now we
have our shortest path
based on this shortest path what system
of corresponding squares
should we use
what system should we use
see a learner's point when i say
shortest path i don't mean anything
based on the current king's position
i just mean uh the shortest path between
the two squares
the shortest path where you can attack
one of the key squares
and then leave that square and go and
attack the other one
so of course it's the eighth square
system so let's build the eight square
system
i'm not going to use colors because
colors are cheating
all right we have our eight square
system now what can we do
to actually solve the study now that
we've determined
what system we have here
how can we actually solve the study now
that we know what system we're dealing
with
yeah you just extend the squares by
skipping
and look at how easy this study actually
is
with this system look at how easy it is
you find the key squares that's the hard
part
you find the shortest path you discover
which system it is because we just know
and then you extend it out so you extend
it out
and it turns out that black is on the
course
on g6 well black is on g8 which is
essentially the same square as g6
and so we want to step to the same
square so we extend d3
which corresponds to g6 out to b3 out to
b1
and we have our first move now king g7
what should be played here well let's
look at our corresponding squares i'm
not going to use
any circles this time because that's how
confident i am
so we have this 8 square system versus
this 8
square system d4 corresponds to f6
so c3 should correspond to king g7
which means king c1 should be played
extending out c3 as such
and now let's say black tries to rush
towards
towards the center to f6 we know f6
corresponds with d4
which extends to d2 so king d2
and now we can battle the black king
back
and win the game or if he steps to g6
trying to be a little bit more uh more
clever
of course g6 corresponds to d3 in our
system
and now black once again has to choose
between the two paths
king f6 we step um
to the same square now the king has to
step away and we can play e5 and win the
game
and if king g5 we go king e3 it's again
the king steps away
and we win the game all right beautiful
stuff
so easy
took three minutes for us it's just that
easy
we need sharpie markers how are we
supposed to just visualize this
well if you if you follow this system i
think it's actually not so unrealistic
to actually visualize it right
like here let me put my money where my
mouth is
right and try this against stockfish
here okay you guys ready for this
i wasn't planning to do this but we'll
try this out
i will play against stockfish level
eight with the white pieces here
right can you guys actually see what's
happening you guys can actually see
what's happening that's wonderful
all right so i know king b1 is the first
move i just remember
all right he goes king h8 so where are
our squares
this this these eight squares against
these eight squares
so he's on the one that corresponds with
h6 what's h6
well g5 and e3 correspond h6 and d2
correspond
d2 jumps over to b2 so king b2
right now stockfish goes to h7
h7 uh
is corresponding in our system this is
our eight squares
these eight squares corresponds to c2 so
we step to c2
g7 now is c3 g6
is d3 and wouldn't you know it he has to
choose between the two
and i go e5 and win the game
i'm not going to play this one out
because i don't want to waste your
guys's time too much
but there there you have it it's just
that easy
right just that easy pull this back up
here
so you just build your system all right
now
if you guys remember my first lecture on
corresponding squares i ended rather
pessimistically
by presenting this position and saying
good luck solving this one there's just
so many squares i don't see how it could
ever be done
but now with our newfound knowledge of
these systems
i think this position very easily can be
solved
i should mention by the way that last
study that we just looked at
was composed by lockic all the way back
in 1892
and this one is a famous study by lasker
uh former world champion and reichhelm
back in 1901
so step one identify the key squares
so larry goodman um in that particular
study i think
that uh the squares did line up in that
pattern
but they're not always going to line up
in that pattern which is why it's good
to know
this uh this system where we find this
eight square triangle if we can
and then build out from there and then
we can always rely on that to help us
out
so you guys have it right b5 is a key
square if white gets to b5 he gets to
take on a5 and win the game
other key squares are g5 and h5 uh
beautiful stuff
what's the shortest path i'm not going
to waste your time with this question
actually no i'm not going to waste your
time with this question right
the apparent one is c4 d3 e3
f3 g3 h4 in this case though
it's very important to notice that white
actually has a bit more
uh leeway in this one there's a bit more
ambiguity
because he could also step to e2 and
this path is just as short
as stepping through e3 right
similarly he could also step to f2
uh so this is actually our shortest path
with both the e3 and the e2 squares and
the f3 and the f2 squares
and black's shortest path is similarly
going to be b6
c7 these two squares these two squares
um actually those two squares
yeah i think those two squares these two
squares
and g6 uh and so this is our shortest
path
now how can we go about building any
system of corresponding squares
from this path what do you guys think
this path
should be all we need to build our
glorious system here
should be all we need
so yeah c6 would also be a square that
white wins
if he achieves it but b5 is already an
easier key square to get to so c6 is
sort of irrelevant to the study
why not through b7 well we're saying
that black needs to step to b6 to defend
b5
right he needs to be on b6 to defend b5
when white's on c4
this is the shortest path right this is
the end of the path to defend b5
as far as why not a6 well it's a longer
path
right takes one two three four five six
versus the five moves
from b6
so yeah chess king says uh this one
looks like
the quadratic so which squares
are you using from the shortest path to
build your pattern chest king let's
start with that
which squares should you use from these
options
along the shortest path to build your
[Music]
system
[Music]
all right try one more time chest king i
don't think that's what you actually
meant to type
c3c2d2 i don't
believe that's quite right if you meant
c4 c3 and d3
then you would be correct i'm going to
give you the benefit of the doubt there
so the trick here is that you never want
to use
any of these ambiguous squares when
trying to make your corresponding square
system
the reason for that is when you have
this ambiguity for both sides
there's a lot more options right
whenever white steps to e3
or e2 black can be on either of these
squares
which means it's not going to be very
restricting it means black is going to
have
options right if black ever needs to
pass he actually can if he's on d7 he
just goes to d8 and it's essentially the
same
so you want to choose squares with the
least ambiguity as possible
which means that c4 and d3 are the
squares on the shortest path that you
want to choose
similarly it'll be
b6 and c7 for black
now can you make an eight square system
here it turns out you cannot
because of course this square is
defended right so you can't go
around the outside as we would very much
like to i'm gonna say that at least
eight more times
so we just need a linking square
then in the middle and we have to figure
out where to build
uh our quadratic system where do we
build our two by two
square now so we have our linking square
on these diagonally adjacent squares and
now how do we build our
our our two by two square
how do we build our two by two square
where does it go
so not quite chess king when you build
the two by two square
outs as we saw in the
second study in the review you want to
choose
either either side of the base triangle
you want to choose one of these sides
whichever side works for you
in this case the left side does not work
right the left side is defended by the
pawn on a5
so we have to use the bottom side here
of our base
triangle we can't use these squares
that you were mentioning because it's
not closely enough connected to our
triangle
see larry goodman and ariane all have
everybody has it now
these four squares right so what do we
get
we get a four square system just as
before
for black it's going to be uh on
c8 for
uh for d2 right you see how this square
corresponded with this square
and we're done with that for now because
it's not actually a part of our
our quadratic system and this square
was corresponding with c7 because it's
between
c4 and the king side on the shortest
path
just as c7 is between b6 and the king's
side on their shortest path
we have c3 corresponding to b7 d2
is behind uh d3 so it's c8 behind
c7 for black and c2 corresponding in
this case
2b8 whoops just punch the microphone
hopefully that wasn't too bad for you
guys
so now how do we extend this out to
actually solve the study i'm going to
get rid of these other confusing
circles for you guys here
how do you color the circles red and
blue leaches has some very nice
shortcuts
if you hold down the alt key and right
click it turns blue if you hold down the
shift key
and right click it turns red i believe
and if you hold down both alt and shift
it turns
turns yellow so of course the answer is
in fact
to play king b1 in the initial position
to win the game
uh why is that
let me double check it's king b1 right
yeah it's king b1 why would i even doubt
why is that well because black is on the
extension
of c7 and so white needs to step to the
extension of d3
which is of course king b1 and just for
kicks we're going to do it against
stockfish again just to prove that the
system
actually works here here we go
real time
oops i ruined everything i ruined
everything it's all over
it's all over bad ideas bad ideas all
around perhaps it's a sign
i like showing off though so we'll do it
we'll do it anyways let's see if i can
beat stockfish here king b1 first move
everybody agrees right okay it chose to
step
to b7 we have these four squares and
those four squares
right so what does king b7 correspond to
for us well king b7 corresponded
to uh king c3 right
it was the linking square between these
two squares that formed our base
triangle so i should of course
step to c1 the extension of c3
now he steps to
c7 which is of course the extension of
d3
so i will step to d1
okay now he steps to
d7 which is of course the extension of
the b7 square which should be
hold on hold on my brain is
frying here
i think i messed it up already i think i
messed it up let's back up let's back up
okay let's slow down here we have these
four squares for us
and these four squares for black correct
so d3
is c7 c3 is b7
right everybody agrees everybody agrees
so it is king c1
okay now he steps
to c7 which is d3 so king d1 okay this
was all right
all right now we have this set up here
so this is b7
b7
is
all right i'm too confused i'm sorry we
got to go back to the study we got to
figure this out got to figure this out
here
king b1 king b7 right everybody agrees
king c1 king c7 king d1 king d7
ah so of course it's king c2 here
everybody knows it's king c2 why is it
king c2
because black no longer has access to
the b8 square this is where i got
a little bit confused okay and why isn't
king d8 good
enough because we are in the main uh
four squares for us right so even though
this is sort of
an extension of uh b8 it's also
farther along on the shortest path than
uh and then b8
then b8 actually is right it's too far
to the right because now after king d8
king c3 black is not going to be in time
to stop us with king c7
right we just go king d3 now stepping to
the corresponding square
and black will have to choose along the
shortest path
so like i'm not gonna lie to you guys of
course it's still complicated as you saw
uh even i who prepared the lecture and
looked at all these things beforehand
could could mess it up so the point was
the tricky part i got confused on there
trying to demonstrate it
was in fact that after king d7 we can
step into the main zone of our
corresponding squares
because d8 does not actually work
for black as an extension of b8 because
we are closer
to the shortest path on the uh
on the queen side here okay does
everybody understand that
does everybody understand that i can do
it against stockfish now if you guys
really want me to
but uh but hopefully that clears up that
confusion
that i myself ran into
the pattern does work the pattern does
work it works i promise
is that a rule just for the quadratic
does that play to the eight square rule
as well
uh so that's where
the distance to the shortest path is
actually going to be uh
going to be relevant now for
white it's not relevant in this case the
reason for that uh and it wasn't going
to be relevant for
white in the other cases as well because
black was never actually threatening to
invade right
white is covering all three of the entry
points here now if this pawn on d4
wasn't here king b1 actually wouldn't be
winning because black has this chance
for counter play
so if black doesn't have this chance for
counter play
then you can sort of just extend out
this pattern for white
right but if black does get counter play
then um
then the extensions start to not work
and so while it doesn't seem like
counter play
in this case for um king b1
for yeah for this while this doesn't
seem like counter play
it is in fact the same idea right white
is just threatening to invade
and so because of that black has to uh
be in the same
uh main four squares as white
if he steps back into these guys of
course we step to the corresponding
square
king c8 corresponds to d2 so of course
we would just step to d2
and he can either match us over here
when we go king c3
when of course uh king b7 the
corresponding square is unavailable
then here we step back and it's the same
idea
all right let's move on to one more
study
show a stock fish all right i'll do it
really really quickly really really
quickly
don't want to waste too much time here
all right give me white here we go king
v1
it's going to play the same moves so
it's going to be rather
anti-anticlimactic climactic
king d7 king c2 now because it can't
step to b8
okay king c um c7
is the same as king d3 so i'll step here
king b7 now is abandoning the king side
so i step this way and come take all his
pawns
right he's too far away from the key
squares now
and i win all right everybody everybody
agrees
everybody agrees alright so let's move
on to the next study
this one is by oops a little bit a
little bit of a spoiler there this one
is by halber stotz
in 1930 and once again
let's try and identify the stuff that we
already know here
right let's get a little bit more
practice with
these two systems that we're aware of
and then after this i want to introduce
to you
a third one that you guys might actually
be a little bit more familiar with
make a three by three box for the system
you make a two by two box
and then extend it can do the big
extendo
so key squares for white in this case
says quadratic obviously all right we'll
get to it we'll get to it
so h6 is going to be a key square and in
fact g6 is going to be a key square as
well right
the threat of pawn to g6 is going to be
good enough to win
and now c4 is not actually going to be a
key square
because king a5 would be able to block
you there
but it does turn out that b4 is enough
for a key square it's not immediately
obvious why
but let me just explain it by showing
you over the board
if white does end up being able to take
on b4 black cannot keep the king boxed
out of a5
and after the gets to a5 white is able
to break through and after this
sorry uh d5 as soon as this pawn leaves
the c6 square
is the winning idea for white now how
can you come by this conclusion
well you just have to sort of calculate
that bit out
uh using chess skill like that's not the
job of corresponding squares here that's
the chess work you have to put in before
you start using corresponding squares
so if white gets to play king takes b4
he wins the game
because he sees this idea of b5 d5
e6 g6 alright everybody loves
that incredible winning idea i'm sure so
we have our two key squares
or our you know two entry points right
we have b4 and we have g6 and h6
king c4 isn't good enough because king
a5 would still box this out so
what happens here then what's our
shortest path
well we have c4 for white d3 e2
f1 g2 h3 h4 h5 right this is our
shortest path
what's black's shortest path well a5 a6
b7 c8 these two squares these two
squares
f8 and g7 right and you see how
we meet at opposite sides of the board
one two three four
five six seven eight one two three four
five six seven eight equal lengths as
always
so now based on this
what's system of squares should we use
in this study
and how should we build it
so what's the first step to making it
well we need to choose
two squares along this shortest path
for both sides i need to choose two
squares
does it need to be of equal length well
if white's path is shorter than blacks
then obviously
white can just travel along the path and
he'll get to the other side before black
and win the game
if blacks is shorter than whites i think
sometimes that does occur
but i could not name a specific example
for you
so danilo says d3 in e2 and that's
actually
perfectly accurate it does turn out in
this case
that there's actually two other squares
that you can use you can actually use e2
and f1
if you prefer and the reason for that
is because the main four squares that
you end up with are actually identical
if you choose d3 and e2 of course you
cannot construct an eight square system
because this is in the way
very important but the four squares you
come up with
are these four now if you choose e2 and
f1
of course you can't construct an
8-square system because the board is too
small
but you can build the same four squares
off of the other
base of the triangle right so it doesn't
really matter you end up with these four
squares either way
similarly for black uh d3
and e2 are a6 and b7 so he ends up with
a7 as the linking square and these four
squares
for black so that's all i'm going to
give you that's
all i'm going to give you okay
so now we have white to move and
win what do you think wait to move and
win
how can you do it how can it be done
we built our system of corresponding
squares you guys know how to extend it
out
so the question is how to make progress
here
so we have three different answers we
have king c1 king c2 and king b1 all
being suggested
that is tough that is truly tough
[Music]
all right does e1 correspond with a8
are we sure about that and this is our
shortest path
and this is our shortest path right
that's your sort of reference point
there
the shortest path
so yeah i do think king b1 is going to
be the most accurate in this case
uh the less good thing about this study
compared to the other ones
is that white is going to be winning no
matter what you play because you're
always able to sort of uh
dance around black in this case because
he only has this one square
on c8 he doesn't have c7 available which
is sort of tough for him but king b1 i
do believe
is the most accurate because you step to
the corresponding square
uh to a8 right a8 is c8
a8 corresponds with d1 right it's sort
of the
square that's on the back corner
compared to the shortest path
for both sides that's how you can tell
they correspond so king b1 is the most
accurate
now if black chooses king
d8 of course we would step to the
corresponding square to b8
if you get steps to a b it or b7 then
the answer for us is rather simple right
he steps to b7 that corresponds with e2
so we step to c2
he steps to b8 we step to c1 right
we keep both of our options open here as
white
uh why is this always winning well
because white is always able to sort of
uh dance around black with these king b2
king b1 options
so king b1 i think is the most accurate
and then like i said
if king b8 we step to the corresponding
square
on c1 now
if he steps to a8 we go king d1 if he
steps to
a7 we go king d2
if he steps to b7 we go king
c2 i believe right king c2
can be seven if he tries passing now
then again
he is stepping too far away from the
shortest length here so we are able to
just
come take this pawn uh
because he's abandoned the shortest path
if he steps to
a7 that's a slightly better try but now
what corresponds to a7
of course it's going to be the square on
d2
and up we go and we win
the game through that technique that we
saw a little bit earlier
so excellent job on that one now i am
going to run a little bit over time here
uh so danilo it does actually depend uh
in this case even if like black's path
was somehow magically shorter
he wouldn't be able to win because he
would have to stick around to make sure
the white king doesn't get over here
right white would just be able to draw
by leaving his king like right here
if white's path was shorter then of
course white would win he just
goes the other way right
um okay so any questions on this one
before i move on
to a final system that i want to
introduce and then i'm going to have
some closing thoughts
on these system of corresponding squares
because
the three things that i the three
systems that i've shown you or the two
that i've shown you and the third one
i'm going to introduce
are not actually all inclusive but they
are the basic building blocks
so you guys are asking this hypothetical
question like what if black has a
shorter path
and to be honest with you i cannot think
of any specific examples where this
happens
uh in studies so i i do not have a
confident answer for you
but um so yeah i don't have a confident
answer for you on if black's path is
is somehow shorter but we'll take a look
at some
studies that might give you a little bit
more clarity on it
this is basic seems hard so the study
itself is is pretty difficult right it's
a pretty complex version
of the basic quadratic uh corresponding
square system
but what i'm saying is you can get more
complicated systems than the quadratic
and that eight square system
uh so the last system that i want to
introduce to you
is what's known as the triangular system
so as with the quadratic system you use
it when you don't have enough space
to construct the eighth square system
with the triangular system
once again you use this one when you
don't have enough space
to construct a quadratic system
we are a little bit short on time so i'm
going to introduce to you
our shortest path here already all right
b6
is obviously a key square for white
and then we have this strange uh
past pawn on the sixth and due to this
past pawn
we can construct the other end of our
shortest path right
so if king c 5 of course black needs to
play king c7
to prevent white from invading but we
can actually create
a another end of the shortest path
thanks to this pawn
on c6 so as we know from
king and pawn end games uh
let me just do something here if the
black king is on c8s
and our white king is on d6 we can play
c7 and win the game
that's just how it works with the pawn
on the sixth
so whenever the white king steps to d6
in order to draw
black must step to d8 right then after
c7 check he can go king c8
and we have nothing better than
stalemate in this case
so we have here our shortest path
for both sides what happens now if we
try to construct our eight square system
well white has enough room but quite
obviously black does not he ran out of
board space
what happens if we try to construct our
quadratic system
when we take the linking square here it
looks like black might have enough space
on the left but this pawn unfortunately
takes away this square
from black so he doesn't have enough
space
so what do we do when we don't have
enough space to make either system
well we get a rather basic triangular
system
in effect here and the way the
triangular system works
is you start with these three basic
squares
in your system uh d5 corresponds to c8
it's the linking square
c5 to c7 and d6 to d8 and this looks
like even more basic than the quadratic
one rather than four bit
four main squares we only have three so
there's one with eight
one with four and now one with three in
fact
so here white looks like he's not
winning at first glance right
because black is already on the
corresponding square and it's
white to move but this is where
your triangulation comes into play
that many of you may be familiar with
and triangulation
actually usually occurs in these
positions where you have this triangular
setup
of corresponding squares so in this
position
white is winning because you can extend
out
this uh d6 square
back to d4 similarly to how we've seen
it work in previous systems
but now the key difference here is that
c4
is also going to be related to d6 why
is that well because you're threatening
to step to the same two squares
from c4 as d4 so what we have
here is uh
what you might have remembered from the
last lecture i didn't include this in
this lecture but last lecture we took a
brief look at the quadratic system with
the
ambiguous uh back two squares which is
what these are
these squares are ambiguous meaning
they're sort of acting as the same
whereas black only has uh only has
b8 to kind of act as this backward
square
right so why does white win well white
wins because he can triangulate
using the fact that these squares are
ambiguous and black only has this one
square to match
so we can step back to
d4 now of course let's build these three
squares again
uh there there there black can
choose to step to the corresponding
square on d8 or the corresponding square
on b8 either one is the same but after
he chooses
white is not going to step up to one of
these two squares when black could match
him
but he'll step to the other green square
and now
black has the unfortunate decision
between stepping to red
or blue when in either case white is
going to be able to win
by stepping to the same color king c7
king c5
if king c8 king d5 and now
white has successfully triangulated and
it is black to move in the initial
position
therefore white is winning so that's
where this idea of triangulation
sort of comes into play it's when white
has this excess
uh corresponding square where he can
pass time
whereas black cannot so that is the
third type of system
that i wanted to introduce now as my
wrapping up words yeah so king c4 also
wins in the exact same way you guys are
absolutely right you go king c4 king d4
because these two squares are ambiguous
right they act as the same square
either king c4 or king d4 both win the
game in this case
um these are the three main
basic systems of corresponding squares
that
were introduced in comprehensive chess
endings that where i got most of this
material
from highly highly recommend that book
and these are the three main systems
that make up
the vast vast majority uh almost all
of the corresponding squares studies
that you'll run into and positions
involving corresponding squares
now of course it does get more complex
than one of these three systems there
are positions
where uh the most common more
complicated case
is you'll run into positions where with
this shortest path
you'll get two of these systems that
sort of are halfway interlinked
so if you get a halfway interlinked uh
quadratic system like you have a
quadratic system here
quadratic system here and they're
sharing this one middle file
you get a six square system which is
pretty intuitive
and you can get two eight square systems
actually
uh connected to each other to make a 13
square system
but they're all combinations of those
basic
systems that we looked at so these are
the basic building blocks
and i think this is enough to solve i'm
going to say like 90
of corresponding squares studies that
you're going to come across
if you do want to go that extra mile and
learn the rest of them
i recommend getting that book by uh by
averbach and again the chapter i believe
is by mikhail
zarin but i think this is where i'm
going to conclude
my study of corresponding squares on
this youtube channel we went
pretty in depth here um
like i said those three basic patterns
are what make up i'm gonna say ninety
percent
ninety plus percent of corresponding
squares end games and the other ones
tend to be combinations of those basic
patterns kind of put together
you can of course also make things more
complicated by giving both sides like an
extra tempi
then both sides have the option to
transpose into other systems of
corresponding squares
that's another way to make it more
complicated and then there
are a just a few really oddball studies
that seemingly for no reason at all
changed the system of corresponding
squares ever so slightly with two
squares being shifted over one square
being shifted over
but those are very very few and far
between they're very much the exceptions
to this rule which holds
almost entirely true all the time so any
final questions for me on corresponding
squares
before we wrap this one up and call it
quits on our study any final questions
so jk rowling asks would this concept
work with aid square
versus quadratic if one side has the
eight square system
available and the other side has the
quadratic system available you have to
just choose the quadratic system
uh that goes back to
uh one of these goes back to one of
these
uh i think this one would accurately
show it
um so
black has now this would wouldn't
actually wouldn't accurately show it
not sure if i could show you an example
here but
uh it would just default to the
quadratic system the eight square
system only works if both sides have all
eight squares available to them just
trust me on that one i guess
so yeah that is the book peter peterson
uh comprehensive
chess endings is of course the series
and then volume four
is the one on pawn endings and there is
that chapter on corresponding squares in
there as well
do all of the top chess players use
these concepts so there are a variety of
ways
that uh people have
used a variety of methods that people
have used to
find corresponding squares and positions
verretsky has
this system of you know looking at mind
squares
but that one is very much on a
case-by-case basis and you sort of have
to examine the entire position
to figure it out which is why i really
like this system
laid out by zarin and offerbox book
because it's it's it's more of a system
right you take a look at a pattern you
recognize what's going on
and then you can build your system out
from there
so the problem is uh jk you would have
that extra space you would have extra
space to extend out your quadratic
system
but it wouldn't really be an eight
square system it would just be an
extension of the quadratic system
right because your eight squares would
have nothing to correspond to
there's no there's no corresponding
square on the other side of the board it
would just be an extension
of the quadratic system um
all right i am going to call it quits
here
uh thank you guys so much for sticking
with me on these corresponding squares
lectures i know they are
really heavy stuff and they are sort of
brain melters
but uh i have a lot of fun going over
these hopefully
you learned a lot about corresponding
squares be sure to join us
on twitch now as i do the
final class for the night analyze your
games that is it for youtube
as always my name is caleb denby and i
want to thank you
very much